a quick question about compression do
you think the human mind can be
compressed the the biology could be
compressed we talked about space travel
to be able to compress the information
that captures some large percent of what
it means to be me or you and then be
able to send that at the speed of light
wow that's a big question and let me try
to take it apart unpack it into several
pieces I don't believe that wetware
biology such as we are has an exclusive
patent on in on intellection
consciousness
I suspect that other structures in the
universe are perfectly capable producing
the data streams that we use to process
first of all our observations of the
universe and and an awareness of
ourselves I can imagine other structures
can do that also so that's part of what
you were talking about which I would
have some disagreement with
consciousness yes what's the most
interesting part of consciousness of us
humans is consciousness is the thing I
think that's the most interesting thing
about you and then you're saying that
there's other entities throughout the
universe I could imagine I can well
imagine that the architecture that
supports our consciousness again has no
patent on consciousness just a in case
you have an interesting thought here
there's folks perhaps in philosophy
called Pan cyclists that believe
consciousness underlies everything it is
one of the fundamental laws of the
universe do you have a sense that that
could possibly fit into I don't know the
answer that question one part of that
belief system is Ghia which is that
there's a kind of conscious life force
about our planet and you know I've
encountered these things before I don't
quite know what to make of them I my own
experience and I'm I'll be 69 in about
two months and I have spent all my
adulthood thinking about the way that
mathematics interacts with nature and
with us to try to understand nature and
all I can tell you from all of my
grated experience is that there is
something extraordinarily mysterious to
me about our universe this is something
an Einstein said of from his life
experience as a scientist and this
mysteriousness almost feels like the
universe's our parent it's a very
strange thing perhaps to hear science
say it scientists say but there are just
so many strange coincidences that you
just get a sense that something is going
on
well I interrupted you in terms of
compressing what we're down to we
consented at the speed of light yes so
so the first thing is I would argue that
it's probably very likely that
artificial intelligence ultimately will
develop something like consciousness
something that for us will probably be
indistinguishable from consciousness so
that's what I meant by our biological
processing equipment that we carry up
here probably had does not hold a patent
on consciousness because it's really
about the data streams I mean that's as
far as I can tell that's what we are we
are self actuating self learning data
streams that to me the most accurate way
I can tell you what I have seen in my
lifetime about what humans are at the
level of consciousness so if that's the
case then you just need to have an
architecture that supports that
information processing so let's assume
that that's true that that in fact what
we call consciousness is really about a
peculiar kind of data stream if that's
the case then if you can export that to
a piece of hardware something metal
electronic what-have-you then you
certainly will ultimately that kind of
consciousness could get to Mars very
quickly it doesn't have our problems you
can engineer the body as I said there's
a ship or a body you engineer one or
both send it at a speed of light well
that one is a more difficult one because
that now goes beyond just a matter of
having a data stream and so now the
preservation of the information in the
data stream and so unless you can build
something that's
like a super super super version of the
way the internet works because most
people aren't aware that the Internet
itself is actually a miracle it's based
on a technology called message packaging
so if you could expand nc8 message
packaging in some way to preserve the
information that's in the data stream
then maybe your dream becomes true
you